Wow!
Hello, everybody!
Hello, hello!
Oh my god.
Sorry, I had to push back the stream 50 minutes later
because, like, I always need, like, a little cool-down
in-between streams.
Um, I didn't expect the other stream to last for this long!
It was- it went a lot longer than I expected it.
I was not expecting it.
Um, to be fair, it's also- it was my own fault that the
stream did last an hour longer than it should have uh
because you know i decided to yeah i decided to prolong it a
little bit longer because i wanted to pick and choose the
placements of monopoly um i was very surprised that i did
win in the end because i thought like oh all i had to do was
land on pippa square and that was it but then like i never
got to land on it
I don't know how apparently I'm unlucky in life, but very
lucky in video games, which I don't know I don't know if
that's like better or not like I would like to be lucky in
life as well That's true.
That's true.
I wanted the true monopoly.
I wanted true monopoly and took off all the properties I saw
someone in my comment section was like how many vtubers does
it take to start to to start monopoly one literally me How
to start Monopoly
Literally one and it's me But no one listened They were like
Oh I just thought about listening to Philly And I'm
listening to Philly Except instead of me
Um Um But yeah And that was a good time Um a good time to to
relax with some fallout for um i was thinking about i was
thinking about doing a should i do a strength build should i
go all in on the games chat like on melee do i do it all in
on melee melee and two intelligence i feel like i'm gonna
myself over with that but like the RP also my you might
might see the game on you guys might see the game but I
don't why is it a black screen I don't I don't see the game
at all I just see I see the game on okay I'm gonna restart
my game I see it on my stream but I you guys can see it but
I can't I can't see the game.
It's okay.
Todd intended it, guys.
We all know.
Todd decides what I can see and what I can't see.
Do you guys see this?
You guys see this, but I don't.
Oh my god, why?
Okay, let me Google this.
Black screen.
Fall out.
Okay, it's okay.
It's okay.
Todd intended this, guys.
Todd.
Todd intended this.
Okay.
I have to go to my what okay and change your settings to the
following excuse me okay let's see give me a sec guys why it
worked before okay i can see this all right i'm look i'm
watching out of my i'm watching it out of my my obs at the
moment okay let's see maybe i can find it on my op is it
because i turned off motion blur is it because i turned off
motion blur that was the only thing i i just changed motion
blur i just didn't want motion blur does todd want me to
have motion blur of course todd of course you would want me
to have motion blur is that why todd did you want me to play
with motion blur on no it's not because of it no okay okay
it's not because of motion blur guys we're gonna figure this
out guys make sure you have the latest okay i got that try
changing change your AA or shadow distance.
This rewrites.
Okay, we gotta change the AA or shadow distance, and then we
should be good.
All right.
It's okay.
It's not his fault.
Okay, I'm turning on motion blur.
What's AA?
I'll call it Anomalous?
What the fuck is AA?
It says change AA or shadow distance.
What the fuck is that?
What's AA?
Okay, I'm gonna put shadow distance at ultra on see all the
shadows and then what the fuck is at oh anti it is okay
we're gonna do uh best performance or best quality okay
we're gonna do all right and then i'm gonna change it back
i'll put put it at best quality and then that should be work
right right todd todd please let me see the game that's all
i want entire i can't see the game i don't oh i know i know
we're gonna listen to this intro like 20 times guys i don't
understand like yeah okay i'm gonna turn off window mode
that has to be it what if i turn off borderless that has to
be it i'll turn off borderless and then i just see it right
i just see the game right right guys i don't see the game
guys i don't see like i don't understand why can't i see the
game i don't understand why don't i see the game okay
turning off window mode it has to be because i have window
mode on that has to be it there's no other way there's no
other reason i see it i see the game i did it guys continue
to believe in todd it'll work all right all right this is it
all you have to do is just believe in him i've always
believed in him all right yay we're in diamond city
yeah dude his name is codsworth wait and codman well hello
there another one of the poor and stupid of diamond city
come begging for
and stupid i have you know i won monopoly the poor and
stupid don't act like you don't know there's two types of
people in this town the ones living in the stands and
everyone i know everyone in the stands and that doesn't
include you now why don't you make yourself scarce bitch
bitch what did you say that's right i'm done talking to you
what the fuck what about killer is she that important you're
in my way how important is she wait give me a set guys uh
new save file
oh she's important she's important guys guys okay i should
just accept my death
wow i just woke up from a really bad dream guys oh my god
what a bad dream
I thought that she was important.
Wait, that's you!
Consworth too!
24 hours?
You sell what?
What do you sell?
What do you sell here?
We also buy any unwanted items you may be carrying on your
house.
They can buy stuff?
Whoa!
I'll take a look.
I want to look.
Okay, can you buy my junk?
Which, I don't know what's junk.
Oh, that's junk, right?
One dollar.
That's one dollar?
This is like my life savings.
How can it be one dollar?
I don't understand.
Like, my entire life savings is in here.
I don't need your handouts.
If you don't want what is my...
If you don't want what's clearly worth so much money, Maybe
you don't understand what Dwarf is.
I don't know where to go.
Do I just explore Diamond City?
Hello.
In the paper to newcomers, if the Institute grabs you in the
night, at least we warned you.
Wait, the Institute?
Institute?
You ain't heard of the Institute, lady?
They snatch people up at the night, and no one hears from
you.
It's all on the paper.
What?
I read up before they grab you, too.
Wait, who's missing?
who's gone missing yeah residents oh people who don't matter
seems every year or so someone's gone and we all know better
be careful newcomer the institute is out there and they'll
grab you too like they don't matter that's i that's whatever
that's nonsense sounds like nonsense you're just like that
rich lady
Um, I'm looking for something.
I'm looking for a missing person.
I'm looking for my son.
Someone's gone missing, right?
That's what I'm telling you.
So who is it?
My baby.
I'm looking for my baby.
His name's Sean.
You have a son, lady?
Wow.
Wow!
I hope the Institute takes you too.
No one tries to find missing people in Diamond City.
Missing people means the Institute.
is and no one's going to want to get the institute's
attention someone can help you're a smart kid isn't there
someone in town I have the charisma I did have the charisma
he's not afraid of wait Nick Valentine he was a tumblr boy
wait what else do you know about mr.
Valentine people drew point of him ain't that the way it is
no one's ever grateful for the people who help out the most
that's not helpful is that all you got kid hey i already
gave you a free paper free advice and a free recommendation
to the detective agency my charity quota yeah but i have a
gun wow god who taught you this this is why you're an orphan
your parents didn't teach you anything because you don't
have any i hope you oh what did i take I don't even remember
what I took.
What was it?
The interstate sounds like a place with a bunch of nerds
that need to get their lunch money taken.
Ryan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I don't even know what I took.
It's okay.
What's Cosworth gonna do?
Fucking leave me?
I literally bought him.
Okay, how do I...
Wait, I need to remember how...
Where's my...
Which one's my, like...
Melee.
It's a three?
Oh my god, I can't remember.
Okay, we're gonna...
Okay, I wanna grab...
Okay, we're gonna put this...
We're gonna put this...
Uh... We're gonna go melee build.
Alright.
Oh, let's see.
Oh, there's the Dragoon Buster.
The Knuckles.
The Fat is 30.
Okay, here we go.
Okay.
Oh, shit!
There's another Cogsword.
But in your case, I should be so disdain.
What?
Let me know when you're ready to order.
Oh my god, he called me poor.
Is there a problem?
No problem at all.
My programming dictates that I...
How do you know I'm poor?
Colonial tap house.
Even those that obviously...
Just know that my senses indicate that you have dangerous...
How?
I live in suburbia.
what how does he know i live in suburbia also sound guy tell
me in like in this the chat not in discord about the sound
but i'll boost up the overall sound by the way guys how did
he know not interested
i can't believe it Looks to be in excellent condition.
Hey.
Yeah, I don't object to your outsiders coming here, but you
must do insist on speaking to me.
What?
Oh, my God.
The robots are talking to each other.
I get to see a model remotely as...
Oh, my God.
They're talking to each other.
It's like talking to yourself.
Believe me, when I...
I do hope our paths will cross again.
Why are they, like, overlapping in volume?
Who let them speak?
They're flirting.
Where do I go?
I keep- I keep fucking accidentally wanting to break into
people's houses.
Oh no, I actually got into a loading screen.
I tricked myself into a loading screen.
Hey, this is between me and my wife.
Whoa.
Why don't you mind your own damn business for once?
Oh god, Paul, why do you always have to make a scene?
Pour me another drink, Henry.
Damn it, Darcy, I just want you to come home.
I'll be home.
Can't believe you do this to your cook.
Do what to you, Paul.
She's an alcoholic.
You keep away from my wife, God damn it.
Whoa!
Fight, fight, fight!
Do it!
Fight!
Come on, talk.
Oh, she's busy.
Go on.
Get out of here.
I'll be at home, Darcy.
What, did she lose?
Oh my god, she has... he has a son?
I want to talk now, or she's still drinking.
I want to talk now?
Sorry I had to see that.
Things are usually a lot quieter around here.
Perfect place to drink if you're buying.
Wait, what's that argument about?
Yeah.
Uh, nothing much.
You see, Darcy here likes to relax and enjoy life from time
to time, and her husband Paul doesn't.
He's not a bad guy, really.
Just a little up there.
Too bad he can't learn to relax, huh, Darcy?
I don't come here to talk about Paul.
You there.
I haven't seen you in here before.
Why don't you make yourself useful and buy me a drink or
something?
Wait, buy a drink?
Have a drink.
You know what?
Have a drink on me.
Drink away your problems.
Whatever she's having.
Well, thank you very much.
I think you and I are going to get along just fine.
Free booze.
The fastest way to your home.
Now, can I just come on?
Wait, why is it over that?
What did I do?
is it because of the how do i cap my ps in game i try to
provide a little oasis from the hardships of life names cook
by the way henry cook let me know if i can get you anything
uh maybe later not a problem okay we gotta fix this what the
fuck happened like everything like
Everything got fucked up in one playthrough.
What did I do?
Oh my god.
Okay, we're gonna save.
We're gonna save here.
This is it.
And then we're gonna quit to desktop.
And then we're gonna play window mode.
Window mode capped the FPS.
So maybe that's it.
It just works, guys.
You don't understand.
You never understand his vision.
Okay, play.
Maybe it'll be better now.
I was like wondering.
I can see!
I can sing.
This is it.
See, I told you.
You always have to trust this.
Trust the process.
God, we should get Todd more money.
All right, there you go.
That should work, right?
Hey, isn't it fabulous?
Sitting up here in the stands.
to do it.
You here for a beer?
I'm just gonna do third person.
I don't like how close I don't like how close they are to
me.
Not interested.
Let me know if that changes.
I'll stop the volume.
If it's better now.
Wait, did I up the volume?
I actually forgot.
I up the volume for real this time.
Okay.
I just don't like how close they are to me.
First person I don't have like, I don't like, I have a lack
of personal space.
I'll need some personal space in between.
I don't like it.
Fine, I'll do first person.
I actually don't know.
People are like, I saw people that were like, wow, this is
like the one, the, Dokki's one of the five people that plays
in third person.
But it's so, everybody is so close to me.
I don't like it.
space i need like a buffer zone yeah i need like a little
buffer
all right let's see can i actually up the fov i can't i
can't even up the fov you liars there's no way yeah i think
the third person is cooler why they're fighting again what
have you done with the real is a synth where's my brother i
swear i'm not a synth don't him shoot him do it don't put
the gun down yeah oh i'm gonna loot him okay shows over
there are no sense in diamond city hear me just you folks in
your damn paranoia yeah there's no sense here i didn't do
anything wrong brother
what did you do what happened what happened i'm i'm not I
learned it before he fell over.
Why didn't he listen to me?
That's what a Sith will say.
I need a minute.
A Sith is a robot, right?
Like an android?
Excuse me.
Also, I brought up the volume a little bit, sound guy.
Wait, what did he wear?
Can I wear his item?
What did I- what was he wearing?
I'll be him.
What was he wearing, guys?
I can be him for him.
Like...
Was it the hide outfit?
The newsboy cap?
I looted so fast that I couldn't even tell.
Oh, the newsboy cap and the padded blue jacket.
Don't worry, I'm him now.
Jesus.
Why not?
I'll be your boy.
brother for you.
Why not?
I'll be your brother for you.
It'll be fine.
I looted so fast that I don't even know.
Alright, nice.
Okay, we need that.
And then we need the raided chest piece.
And then, is that good?
Nice.
Alright, now I look.
Oh, no, I need to take off the hat.
No hat.
Alright.
Where's, like, where's, like, uh, Nick Valentine?
Where is this place?
Diamond City, Diamond City Market.
How do I find local map?
Is it a local map?
Whoa.
Where does Nick Valentine go?
Do you live here?
No, that's the basement.
It's in the alleyway.
It's in the alleyway?
There's so many alleys.
Which one's the right alley?
Is this an alley?
That's a school.
Oh, there it is.
Detective!
It has to be in the greenhouse.
Road to freedom?
Is this not the alleyway?
I'll grab some of this.
Ooh, I got some fruit, though.
Wrong house.
I don't know.
I thought he would be here.
I thought he'd just chill in the greenhouse.
Oh, it's the next door.
Yeah, but it says detectives.
Oh no, I'm stuck in the loading screen again I think that's
like the worst part about Fallout 4 The loading screen The
fucking loading screen Man It's so long Okay Alright it is
It's this way It's down this alley Valentine Detective
Agency there he is Uh Your
luck wouldn't last forever Where is he?
I'm here for the detective.
Oh, Nick.
Another stray coming in from the rain.
I'm too late.
Why?
It's important.
Me and my two charisma is gonna charm you.
No!
He's gone.
Missing.
I can't believe any clues.
Do you have any idea how I could find him?
I need to find this Tumblr man.
Malone's gang had kidnapped a young woman and he tracked
them down to their hideout in Kirk Street Station.
What the fuck is getting him alone?
Down there they use as a base.
I told Nick he was walking into a trap but he just smiled
and walked out the door like he always did.
I don't have failed Riz.
They're just not into me.
I want money.
I'd love to help.
But there's the small matter of expenses.
Money.
Oh, that works?
I want more.
Yeah, this is your fucking boss.
Don't you love him?
What?
It's gonna be a hundred now?
That's the reward.
No!
How could this happen to me?
Who's this skinny Malone character?
I don't know much about him, but he's from good neighbor.
And that means he's in the well-pressed suits and machine
guns.
Boy, if it says good neighbor, that means he's like a good
neighbor, right?
You said Malone's from good neighbor?
Yeah.
Yeah, it's a tough neighborhood.
But it says good.
The people with power there care about two things.
Style and body count.
The greedy gets punished?
That can't be.
I'll find him.
You have my word.
Thank you.
Nick should be easy to spot.
He's always wearing that old hat and trench coat get up.
Please hurry.
I balanced it out.
Contours didn't like it and then he liked it again.
Alright, that's our first quest.
We're going to save Nick Valentine.
Is there anything I can borrow?
Okay.
This.
There we go.
I can borrow this.
All right.
Come on, Cogsworth.
We're going to go save your kind.
One of your kind.
Don't say I'm...
Don't say I'm racist against since now.
I'm literally saving your kind, Cogsworth.
Panoply changed me.
I felt the power.
Okay.
all right back to the loading screen we go okay we gotta
save nick valentine i got a bat for it okay wait what's the
difference between a synth and a robot aren't they the same
or is it like an android thing are synths androids okay good
neighbor is it here you're gonna discover okay he's in the
good neighbor area whoa guys did you know you can do this I
can like move my arms like a real person whoa okay uh is
that it oh they're androids oh so they're like part uh so
they're part uh human oh okay I guess like talk to the
settlers that we're gonna let the settlement die I guess
they're only 22% happy well sucks to be them fucking I guess
depressed then.
Join the club.
Alright, we're gonna go.
Oh no, that's cyborg.
Wait, then what's the difference between and...
Wait, then what's...
Androids?
Are androids?
Oh, androids just look like humans, right?
Androids are synths, so they are not actually human, but
they just look like humans.
Yeah, so they are robots!
Then he is the same!
Cogdorid is just less evolved.
Yeah, they're robots then.
I can't believe it.
You guys are like, no, Doki.
I can't believe you would say that, but the Androids are
practically robots.
They're just synthetic humans.
Exactly.
So he's basically, he's basically like, like Cogsworth.
Except he has legs.
And Cogsworth doesn't.
Yeah, Cogsworth is like...
Uh, the missing link in robot evolution.
Alright, we gotta go find.
Alright, where's my marker?
Oh my god, where's my marker?
I gotta remember how to read the map.
First goal.
Remembering how to read the map.
Do robots have rights?
Of course not.
And they'll never have rights.
As long as I'm in charge.
Okay, we gotta go this way.
Uh, did I not mark it?
I thought I did.
Okay, unlikely.
Yeah, I marked it here.
Uh, and then...
Oh, it's right here.
Okay.
Woo!
Bad dog!
Okay, there you go.
We're fine.
Um...
It's this way.
uh wait no it's not this way oh no oh no yokey is lost
coxworth if you want to start having rights tell me where to
go wait are they good people they're not good people
coxworth go go coxworth that's right do your thing oh my god
it's okay i can outbat him i put it all on strength it's
okay I put it all on strength.
Alright, fuck the strength bill.
Never mind.
What the fuck?
The super mutants!
Guys, remember I saw it?
It would be funny to go get you a strength bill.
Wait, I'm back here.
Okay, guys.
I'm getting a gun.
Guys, I know my place now.
I've always been a gunslinger.
He didn't smash.
I got up.
at it guys i guys i figured it out guys i feel like i was
just not meant to hold i was just not meant to smash i was
just not i was just i came over android's versus cyports is
giving flashbacks to my dragon ball z fan boy fan boy day
shake my head thank you thank you where did all these
security people go when i needed them the most so fucked up
okay it's this way the moment i needed them they were gone
it's all right now i have now i have gun so there's no way i
can lose wait who's that there see there's no way i can lose
now i have gun there you go what the fuck he's not glowing
it's like he doesn't have yellow paint oh there's stuff
there's stuff i love god damn i keep sitting down it was
just a free massage until the super mutants attacked saying
thank you for the super chat thank you i can't believe there
were super mutants they didn't train me for this oh the
public library.
Alright, we go this way.
Like, where did he come from?
Where did he go?
They're gone now.
Alright, guys.
It's okay.
It's an investment.
I'll invest in... Wait, are they bad people?
Wait, they're mannequins.
Why are they naked?
Mannequins there.
Are they naked?
Oh, shit.
Somebody got really lonely.
Alright, we go this way.
I wish I can just drive a car.
Down here.
What?
Did you hear that?
Cosworth, did you hear that?
There's a person here.
Cosworth, go!
Go, Cosworth!
They shot a gun!
It's a psycho!
Nice.
See, assault, assault, raid.
Okay, here we go.
Nice.
Free loot.
Free fucking loot.
I love free loot.
Get over here, Cosworth.
No, Cosworth, go!
Alright, this way.
Am I close?
Where am I?
Oh, I am close!
It's like literally like next door.
Ah, this way.
It's like 60 meters away.
Cosworth, I'm gonna replace you.
Oh!
i can never tell if it's water everything is just brown and
black like how can i tell it's water blends in oh how is
this radiation i say as i look at the fucking barrels of
radiation i can't believe it how can that be radiation oh i
leveled up oh nuka cola there's no nuka cola for Nukakola.
How do I get in here?
Oh, there it is.
Wait, shoot the water?
Why should I shoot the water?
This one?
Guys, don't shoot the water.
Guys, guys, loading screen.
Loading screen.
Someone
would prep the boss music.
It's okay.
Jesus, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's okay.
I got saved by the loading screen.
The loading screen saved.
I got clutched.
The water was slightly angry.
He and me.
It's okay.
He'll go back into the water after, right?
Right?
He's gonna go back to the water, right guys?
It's like nothing bad happened.
Chat.
It's like, it's like I didn't do anything wrong.
See, look at that!
We're safe, Kongs!
Where if we didn't!
We're safe!
Joining Skinny Malone's crew was the best decision we've
ever made.
Where the fuck is Skinny, man?
Oh yeah, Skinny Malone.
We caught that detective snooping around him.
What does he do?
Locks your mic.
see me it's okay Cosworth go do your thing I'm gonna watch
go Cosworth go shoot him yeah it's just a scratch do your
thing go go out there he's over there oh yeah that's right
yeah you do your thing Cosworth body block for me I don't
need to use that I don't need to use vats if I kept your aim
look at that Am I getting shot from the back?
It's okay.
We're okay.
I don't know remember how to heal.
Guys, how do I heal?
What was up heal button?
Three.
Guys, it was not three.
I got the baton.
Oh, no.
I don't remember which one was healed.
Do I not have heals?
Converse, please.
Please body block.
I have to remember how to heal.
Aid.
Okay.
Do I give radiation with this?
That should be fine, right?
We're fine.
See?
Oh, body block.
Oh, he's not fine.
There you go.
It's fine.
We're fine.
We're okay.
We're okay, guys.
Cosworth, get up!
I'll shoot him in the deck for you!
We're okay.
Everything's fine.
Oh, that's radiated?
Oh!
okay it's it's fine everybody i can shoot him in the arm no
okay that that he can shoot through the walls but i can't
this is bullshit this is actually bullshit going in there we
go we're okay we're okay nothing is nothing bad is gonna
happen guys look see he's fine all right we actually got it
like inspect plus one rad okay no we don't need the rad how
the fuck oh there it is there's the rad okay minus one
intelligence plus one strength two rad when do i not get rad
okay two rad oh nuka cherry that's like five rad i can take
that risk that's a risk i'm willing to take
yours.
Then I'm going to take all the junk as well.
Oh shit, money!
Look, everything's fine.
Okay, we can pick this.
Uh.
Is it A?
Okay, now.
Yeah!
First try!
Oh my god!
And money?
It's my birthday!
a bucket?
Wait, I think that's purified water, was it?
Okay.
Alright.
Cogsworth, I need you to do something.
Cogsworth, get over here.
Hey.
Alright, trade.
Alright, I need you to hold my stuff.
Let's see.
I need to do a sort.
What's this?
Bottle cap mine?
Why would I need a mine if I can just... Okay, three weight
zero weight 12.6 this has to be okay we're gonna put away
extinguisher okay we're gonna put away that we're gonna put
away this we're gonna put away this we're gonna start no i
need my gun oh no i put away my gun guys oh no it's okay
it's okay we'll be fine we have other guns we have so many
other guns guys we'll be fine okay and then you hold all of
these you can't carry more what's the point if you can't
keep carrying stuff what's the point oh shit okay we need a
i don't even know what i'm holding on to anymore there's too
many things guys i'm like guys i think i have a hoarding
problem
Guys, I'm not sure yet, but I think I have a small issue.
Just a little bit of an issue.
Wait, can I upgrade stuff now?
Oh, I can!
Alright, what do we do?
Guys, someone said I should do an idiot savant.
Does she revert to self-arsher sniper?
Thank you for the switch at Platypus.
Thank you.
Where's Idiot Savant?
Where is that?
Am I dumb enough?
Luck?
But where is it?
Do I just need to do luck more?
In the luck tree?
Okay, Idiot Savant.
Mystery.
Oh, there you go.
I need five luck.
Okay, we gotta invest in luck, guys.
Alright.
Nice.
What is the Idiot Savant?
Everyone keeps telling me to do it.
You're not stupid.
Just...
Guys, I'm not stupid.
See?
Even the game doesn't think I'm stupid.
I fucking knew it.
I knew I wasn't stupid.
The game was right.
All right, here you go.
Just different.
You guys just don't understand.
All right, loot, loot, loot, loot.
Hello?
Oh, this is a terrible gun!
Okay, this gun was terrible.
Alright, we're gonna do pistol.
Pistol was the key.
It's always the key.
Alright, let me eat.
Guys, it's okay if I get a little bit of radiation.
Uh...
Oh my god, it's full HP.
That's good.
Where is he?
See, look!
it's so much easier all right go Cosworth go I can actually
headshot oh my god why do they have actual guns and I have a
fucking BB gun they get real guns I'm shooting a fucking BB
gun I shoot his foot there you go oh my god guys it's It's
gonna be okay.
It's gonna be okay.
Cosmere is taking everything for me.
Which one was fast again, guys?
I don't remember!
Cosmere, please!
Okay.
Cute.
All right.
it i'm gonna shoot them in the head i have to eventually hit
that right boom there i did it oh i'm a natural oh my god bp
gun is fine if i can hit all these shots i don't know where
i'm getting shot at it's okay no it's not okay
me oh my god oh my god just stop coming back just go for it
oh god okay head head head eventually i'll hit the head
please i just need cogs when you're blocking the bullet no
he blocked the bullet he actually He actually blocked all
the bullets at Cogsworth, you fucking idiot!
He fucking blocked it.
Oh my god, Cogsworth!
I don't ask for much Cogsworth, but I actually don't.
Oh my god, he actually blocked me.
That's actually crazy.
Holy shit.
Can't believe it.
I can't believe he blocked me like that.
Oh, I got reloaded.
I was so ready to shoot my gun.
No, no.
Are you fucking kidding me?
I was so ready to.
He lives that?
Bro, that's some fucking helmet.
No!
Oh my god.
all right we gotta try out some guns real quick wait what
about the pipe no pipe pistol was the fucking shitty one oh
my guys it's back to the BB gun back to the BB gun guys
there you go okay there you go nice I have aim it's okay
Okay.
Is that ghoul?
That's a ghoul right there.
Give me your gun.
Point 45.
I'm going to take that.
That has to be a good gun, right?
The point 45?
Where is it?
Where the fuck is it?
Where's your gun?
What gun did you have?
Oh, no.
I don't know what gun he had.
He's dead now.
Alright.
Okay.
He has to get closer.
Right?
Okay.
Oh, here.
He also has a 10mm.
Whoa!
Okay, fuck this.
The 10mm has been the clutch this entire time.
A little bit of red.
It's okay.
I need it.
Guys, I tried the strength build.
And, like, I need more.
Okay, like, it's too difficult to do strength right now.
Okay.
We gotta like guys the reason why we're not doing strength
yet guys is that Is that we don't we don't have like I don't
have sim packs guys The only reason why we can't do strength
build is that we haven't invested properly in strength yet
So like there's nothing we can do I need more armor to focus
on strength We don't have the investments yet, guys.
Like, we're so weak.
I'm just gonna rob...
Oh, no.
Coxruff, I need help.
Coxruff, I took too many items.
Coxruff, we're so poor.
Like, Coxruff, I fucked...
Where is he?
Oh, why am I taking more items?
Coxruff, I need you, Coxruff.
I need you to hold on to my stuff for me.
I fucked up again God's right, I fucked up I took too many
things Okay, we gotta drop Okay, we don't need all of these
Okay, pipe pistol Okay, pipe auto pistol But 10 mm mm It's
just so much better Okay, we don't need 6, 7, 10 mm Alright,
guys, we don't need all of that I can't help it I can't help
it Guys, I just want to keep looting.
Do I have enough?
Okay, there we go.
Guys, I managed to...
I managed to, like, drop some stuff.
Where is he?
Where the fuck is my robot butler?
This is exactly why they don't...
The robots don't deserve any rights.
Holy shit.
They can't even do a simple job as to follow me.
I will never drop the pipe bombs.
Wait, can I drop the...
What is the pipe?
pipe bomb.
This one?
Where is the pipe bomb?
Oh my god, I have grenades.
Harsh but true.
Bro, is that even following?
Where is he?
Like, literally, where is my fucking robot?
Wait, what's this?
Is this the outside?
Oh, I'm outside now.
I went the wrong way.
God's worth has better things to do.
I actually went outside.
I'm trying to save Valentine.
All pipe guns are bad dokey.
But that means I can save.
I can sell it.
It takes a thousand rats to kill you.
That was driving me nuts.
I had to message to say that.
Also, the submachine gun is terrible.
Thank you for the super chat.
There you are, Cogsworth.
Oh my god.
Of course, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
But I could sell it.
I can sell I can sell like the He's That's sick of you that
you Bro if he's sick of me Of using as a mission Then do
something He can stop this if he does anything
Okay He did something he ran away I can't do a melee build
yet i can't do it yet i don't i need to invest in a melee
build i'm too weak if i get close i get fucking shot at by
20 people i'm too weak right now
i miss a skill issue not enough insurance i have 10 i need
more 10 is not enough like 50 holy shit this loading screen
fallout 4 please i heard like you can mod it in a way that
reduces the loading time is that true okay all i hear is
when when just skill issue
oh the world needs more we need more oh my god there is okay
we're gonna figure this out next time because I can't.
Holy shit, that takes fucking forever.
Am I going the right way to saving him?
Like, where is he?
It says here.
Bye, Nick.
Is Nick here?
I guess it was nothing after all.
I'm not nothing.
Oh, God.
Gossip Cogsworth.
Go, go, go, go, go.
Go, go, go.
Go, go.
While I fucking eat.
Go Cosworth.
I need to find food that gives me the most.
Oh, there you go.
Purify water.
All right, go Cosworth.
Go.
Over there.
Oh, God.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, here,
here.
Hit, hit, hit, hit, hit.
Guys, I think it's a bad idea that I'm in the open, guys.
Guys, I think, I don't think I should be in the open,
everybody.
Yeah, I'm having a lot of fun.
Holy shit!
Oh my god.
He's actually doing something.
I'm gonna run.
There's no way he can shoot me.
Okay.
Head, head, head, head.
I have to hit it.
Nope, almost.
No, almost there.
Nope, oh, nope.
That 20% should not have taken that 20% bet.
It's okay.
I can shoot it myself, I guess.
Guys, guys, okay.
I did it.
Guys, I should not have taken that 20% bet.
Yes.
The 20% bet was not in my favor.
Maybe I'm faster than a bullet.
You guys don't know that.
I did it.
Okay.
Fine, I'll play first person.
Fine.
Alright, what's in vault 114?
Yay!
You skinny?
He has me.
That's me.
What was that?
A good person?
Oh!
Nice.
We're okay.
Oh my god, he has a bag!
He's going full mini!
Braver than me.
He truly is braver than me.
Okay, I should stop taking people's clothes.
I really should.
But I can't help it.
Oh, he has potato crisp.
Alright.
Guys, I restrained myself from taking his clothes guys guys
i did it guys are you proud of me i didn't i didn't take his
clothes guys i actually did it all right gotta eat some
bubble gum maybe a corn maybe some cram there you go i'll
take the vegetable starch though that's the sliding door oh
i can open the door open i did it guys i let him have his
clothes on Ooh, purified water.
We need that.
Hello?
Is anybody here?
I'm a good person.
Hello?
Nick?
Oh, that's a ghoul.
Oh,
they weren't planning on using it.
I thought it was, like, a way to, like...
I thought it was, like, a way...
Okay, that's time.
I'm going to take my gotcha.
I know it's going to work.
I knew it!
It hit, guys!
Oh my god, 100 crit.
Oh!
My gotcha was good today.
Gotcha was good to me.
There.
Nice.
I don't have to...
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Wait!
Did you see that?
That's a better gun!
Glow sighted hair trigger.
Oh, my God.
It's radioactive.
Instant mash.
Tenement pistols.
No, I'm carrying too much again.
I have a problem.
I have a hoarder problem.
I...
I have a problem.
There we go.
We got this.
I should eat two.
Aid.
I'll eat some...
You know what?
I'll eat some Instamash.
And some dog meat.
A little bit rage.
I'll find a right away later.
Right?
I'm gonna find right away.
Wait, what the fuck?
Peek me.
Wait, if I go closer...
I have faster fingers.
Oh, shit!
That wasn't it.
Sorry.
I thought I could like out-out shoot him.
No!
Every time!
Every fucking time!
I keep taking more and more stuff.
Okay, we gotta drop this.
We gotta drop all these machine guns.
Okay, here we go.
I should be fine now.
Ooh, double egg, so...
Nice.
Alright, it's this way.
No, I need all these junk.
You don't understand.
You don't understand, dragons.
Oh, shit!
The fastest fingers.
Oh my god, they have an oven mitt.
Hello?
No, you don't.
Oh, wait, duct tape.
Ball peeing hammer.
What's that?
Shock glass, whiskey.
Pre-war money?
What can I do with pre-war money?
We'll drop them off at our settlement later after we find
out.
my neck.
Who's that?
Who's that over here?
I hear somebody.
Okay.
It won't look up, right?
No!
Cosworth!
You bet!
Cosworth actually pushed me!
Oh my god!
He actually pushed me down.
Oh my God, you bitch.
Okay, I know Nick Valentine.
He has he has Oh no, I'm hugging Cumbert again.
No!
Oh my God, look at my collection of guns here.
Alright, nice.
I need to not take that submachine gun.
Alright, this should be it, right?
I found you?
I found him?
The circuit reggated.
I know he can carry my stuff.
I gave him all my stuff now.
So he has everything.
I found the loading screen.
No!
I found the loading.
It's the only thing that's like killing me right now playing
fallout 4 is the goddamn loading screen someone fucking
linked me the mod in bird cedars later after the stream
where i could fucking at least half the time of um the
loading screen i can't i actually can't i can't take this i
was actually me up man
oh oh look at the lights the settlement needs some
flashlights how you doing in there valentine feeling hungry
get him all right no four percent you know what i'll take
the four percent no is that zero now i'll be fine it's just
one guy i could kill one guy get over here
pew pew pew oh my god i might as well shoot in myself oh my
god
bro like i shot bro i don't need the vat system i might as
well shoot in myself it was just it was just faster it was
actually just faster I don't know who you are, but we got
three minutes.
I did it.
Before they realized muscles for brains ain't coming back.
Get this door open.
I gotta get it open.
I'm trying to.
Did I not pick up the overseer?
There's a terminal?
Oh, there you are.
Oh, there's a terminal right here.
I got you.
I'm so good at hacking.
Alright, password required.
Greenswell system.
Oh, override.
Please take a number.
Okay.
Please wait until your number is called.
Have a nice day.
Oh, I can override.
Jokey, the loading gets better.
You turn off V-Sync.
Thank you in the super chat.
Cheating.
Thank you.
Did I turn off V-Sync?
I don't know.
Okay.
I did.
Opening door.
Nice.
Okay.
I did it!
Hello.
You're the one that everybody likes.
I don't understand.
The question is, why did our heroine risk life and limb for
an old private eye?
I'm trying to track a murderer.
I'm tracking a murderer.
The bastard who shot my husband, took my baby.
I don't even have a clue who he is or where he's gone.
So you need a little angel of vengeance, huh?
Yeah.
Well, I don't usually go after blood money, but I guess I
can make an exception.
up in here for weeks turns out the runaway daughter i came
here to find wasn't kidnapped she's skinny malone's new
flame oh he got baited anyway you got troubles and i'm glad
to help but now ain't the time let's blow this joint then
we'll talk do you mean my new companion there we go oh i'll
take it malone's crew here used to be small time What's
this?
Welcome, employees.
I hope this message is finding you well.
You move into your new position.
Your appointment as Overshare came with high recommendation
from our interviewers.
Please do not be nervous.
Oh, that's it?
Okay.
That's it.
Oh, I want to take these.
Oh, I take these.
We just run back to town.
Do I?
Do I have to follow him?
Can I just fast travel back to Diamond City?
Where?
How do you want to play this?
Shoot him.
Nick.
I'm ready to shoot him.
Wait, listen to the tapes?
Which tape did I grab?
I move so fast I never I don't know months ammo, junk where
is it was it this one?
Was it 21 or 21 or 103?
21?
Are you just gonna walk back?
There
you go.
Red Axe!
Oh
my god, they just stopped her interview.
Yeah, she just started.
Yes, yes.
Oh.
Did I mention I was head of my debate team?
I'm sure you did.
Thank you.
She talked too much.
They don't like it.
like it when they talk too much they just want to be
obedient oh food i always need more food yeah they're not
looking for someone competent they're looking for people
like me would need the key oh she he can wait he can hack oh
my god he can hack he's already better than call I need
these wrenches.
I don't know what I'm going to do with them, but I know I
need it.
There's a nursery?
Me?
It's me!
Doki!
Oh, I need these.
I don't know what I'm going to do with it, but I need them.
Shoot him!
Just shoot him!
Oh, I need that too.
that and i need that oh i definitely need this it's a comic
book cogsworth is useless oh it's this way okay uh this way
yeah oh no no not this way oh like this no my bobby pin it's
okay i have a lot i have a lot no oh it should be like here
no like this i know we're in the middle of a gunfight right
now but i need to figure this out yes yay what is that soap
oh it's soap look at all the soap and melons and beer oh my
god i the settlement needs the settlement needs uh needs
needs a broom all right i can eat now let's see i picked up
so much food i must be able to eat now all right i can get
oh but that's two reds is there anything that gives me a lot
purify water i guess i'll take the purify water oh wait i'm
still i forgot to do the one it's okay uh i mean i don't
need seven hats i guess do i do guys i guess i don't need
seven fedoras
I guess.
Alright, here we go.
I should have enough, right?
There we go.
What's that?
Higuana on a stick?
Oh, he has a black baseball bat, though.
Will he be fine?
Can Nick Valentine die?
It'll be fine, right?
Oh, I need an empty can.
No!
But I need all of this!
If only you could.
wear awesome okay i guess i don't need this i guess i don't
need six suits i guess wait i need one of these for armor
okay i don't need the left arm i'm too lazy what's that
wonder glue oh my god we always need glue oh shit there you
go i honestly don't know if they actually have oh my god a
melon I need a melon a pillow the settlement needs more
pillows oh my god I need all these plates guys you don't
understand these plates are so important you don't
understand guys they're so important all right i can get rid
of like i'll get okay fine i'll get rid of like i'll get rid
of the plates okay i'll get rid of the plates but i'm
keeping the pillow
i don't have a problem they're important oh my god we I was
missing looking at the cigarette.
Did you hear the Lord drop the husband being a war criminal?
Jim, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Well, I know he was in the war.
I didn't realize he was a war criminal.
Okay, I'll eat the melon.
I'll eat it.
And I guess I'll eat the...
I'll just have profile water.
It's okay.
He can't die, right?
Okay.
Whoa, he's so tanky.
There you Alright, bottle cap And then I'll grab the bottle
cap And then the rounds Oh my god, can I steal the bike?
Guys, I don't, I swear The toy car!
A toy truck before my toy car!
Guys!
I need all of this!
What else do they have?
A voltage Labcoat?
Alright.
But you can't romance Nick Valentine?
I thought you could.
Then why the fuck is everybody freaking out about Nick
Valentine?
Let's get him alone and the rest of his boys are waiting for
us somewhere.
I don't have a problem!
Oh my god!
A Vault-Tek jumpsuit!
We need that.
Look at all these lights!
I can't loot that!
It's okay.
It'll be fine.
all right it's fine iguana stick what the fuck is an iguana
stick oh i guess oh it's an iguana on a stick i know what
iguana stick is now all right guys i'm gonna eat a little
bit let's see and then we'll eat the fruit guys it's okay
just a little bit of it i should get rid of some stuff no
but what about my okay maybe i don't need all of that fine
i'll Get rid of this.
Open the door, Nick.
Open it.
Where did he go?
Where did he?
Oh, he went outside.
I was like, he disappeared.
Where did he go?
You save those fruits for your settlement?
They don't need it.
What is the happen to my settlement they'll die they'll
starve there's no way zero thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you they'll be fine they'll just need more
plates guys they'll be fine i'll just give them plates they
can just grow more exactly i don't need those fruits when
they can leave They'll leave my settlement?
You mean I actually have to care?
Wait, how much fruits do I have left?
Do I still have fruits?
Guys, I still have fruits.
I still have the muty fruits and the doubled eggs.
How much this is going to set me back?
I wouldn't be here if it weren't for your two-timing game,
Skinny.
You ought to tell her to write home more often.
little valentine ashamed you got beat up by a girl I'll just
run back home to daddy they can't be planted I'm gonna kill
them oh no guys wait I have a need right I do I should have
a need I've courted so much I must have one need haha you
hear me oh nice I do shut us down now that I finally got a
good right How do I take my nade out?
Guys, how do I take my nade out?
Can you just look at it?
Is it G?
Oh, it's M4.
Oh, that stupid crap of the old times.
Oh, it was M4.
Skinny Malone's always got things under control.
Oh, yeah.
Then what's this lady doing here, huh?
Valentine must have brought her here to rub us all out.
Encourage violence.
Oh wait, what's going on for her?
Oh, I actually want to know the lore.
Carla's a runaway.
Her father wanted me to bring her back home.
Turns out she skipped town to be with my old pal, Skinny
Malone.
Mob boss.
Never thought he'd managed to scrape together a big enough
crew to take over a vault.
Guess life's full of surprises.
Hey, who's running this show here?
You got something to say?
Say it to me.
a problem listen to me i'm hotter than her look at yourself
darla is playing you for a sap i have red hair you're better
than her you're you're right oh my god i'm right i knew it
killer saying you're dragging me and this whole operation
down a bad road i told you I told you!
It works because I'm a woman!
I'm a real female!
They always gotta hit you where it hurts.
Now what am I gonna do about you two?
Skinny Malone is not skinny.
That sucks, bro.
I still see your ugly faces after that.
I'm gonna start shooting until there ain't no more bullets
left in this whole vault!
We better get out of here fast.
I fucking did it.
I knew it.
Oh, shit.
Oh, he's counting.
He knows how to count.
Where do I go?
I'll go here?
Valentine, where do I...
Wait, where did he go?
Why is he taking you forever?
Kong's work!
Why are you over there?
Don't worry.
No, I did.
I did call.
He has all my inventory right now.
Okay.
Are you going to leave?
I'll leave first.
I didn't know which exit they're going to take.
There's so many exits.
It's okay.
I have Nick Valentine now.
I have to actually work on my settlement.
This is such a scam.
Why can't it be automated?
I don't understand.
Why do I have to work on the settlement?
It's not fair.
Just let them leave.
Well, if it's me having a fucking house.
I have to work for it.
Alright, it's so cruel.
is the dragoons at the at the sanctuary where's the food i
don't know dragoons where is the food just been eating all
the radiated fucking red roach me get your own food dragoons
farm your own food why are you depending on me i barely can
take care of myself
oh my god it's still loading oh my god please somebody link
me that mod so I can patch it later before after before part
three 90 50% of this playthrough is just loading screens
three years later wait are Cogsward and Nick the same voice
actor wait they're really the same I didn't realize we're
gonna start just eat the egg goons just make them the food
we have the tomato goons and the egg goons just eat um
there's fresh meat that's why survival of the fittest it
just works it just works the loading screen simulator toky
please we're so hungry then look at the dragons it's fine
calabism is fine if it's like for survival um is this is not
i don't think this i don't have enough based on my SSD.
My SSD only has like, has like the important games, like
Apex and Overwatch.
Father, please it's time.
Do I need to start praying the time?
Oh, holy Todd.
Please let me play the game.
All I want to do is go to Diamond City so I can make Nick my
companions Because I'm pretty sure he's a better companion
than Cogsworth.
Please.
That's all I want.
I spent majority of this game in this black screen.
Tied.
Oh, thank God.
Can I turn V-Sync off here?
Alright, vibration.
I don't think that's V-Sync.
No, I cannot.
All right.
guess we suffer all right where do we go where do we go now
you're ready to talk how do you know to find me down in that
old vault uh ellie your secretary ellie she sent me she did
i should give her a raise now you mentioned something about
a missing person no trace of where they've gone my son my
office in diamond city give me all the details Sides, I
think you've earned a chance to sit down and clear your
head.
Oh, okay.
I'll meet you there.
Yeah.
I'll see you in Diamond City.
Yay!
I saved Valentine!
Yeah!
I did it!
Okay, we're gonna...
Ooh, I leveled up.
Hey!
I leveled up.
All right, guys.
I need more luck, apparently.
Right?
I need more luck.
All right, I need, like, five luck.
I have three luck now.
Nice.
Okay, all right, we're gonna travel to our sanctuary so we
can, like, throw some shit away.
Where's my house?
Is it here?
Oh, sanctuary.
Oh, they're 24% happy!
Look, they did it!
All right, thank you, but Super Chat, thank you, thank you.
Doki, I have such a huge muscle.
Why not run?
Use melee weapons or punch.
Thank you, and Super Chat, thank you, thank you, Harry.
Well, you see, we tried that, and then I got shot by 20
people.
that after after getting shot by 20 people it was just not
it it all right nice okay now that i threw all of that away
where's cogsworth cogsworth i know you have items trade okay
give me back all yes i'll take it all up and then and then
I'm gonna transfer and then I'm gonna press store all junk
and um yeah I dumped all the junk that's the junk right I
did it okay prosper I need to transfer some stuff wait there
uh okay and then I'm gonna throw some stuff away you know
what just uh just take some uh just take you know what fuck
it just take this no no don't take that take uh i don't need
all these fusion cells what are the fusion cells for anyway
okay we're gonna put the heavy stuff uh see weight 20 oh my
god no take these what the fuck am i talking about take all
of that that's way too much inventory uh uh and then i'll
throw away i'll keep all of these for now i'm gonna start
selling stuff oh it's ammo oh okay can i build stuff now
okay guys we're gonna figure this out okay we're gonna move
this how do i move this no that's not it how do i move you
um select oh oh whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa okay we're gonna put you here select and then
we're gonna put you here and then and then i'll put you here
and then we put you here attach wires wait can i attach it
to the water pipe does the water pipe need water electricity
that's stupid doky why did you say that d are you is it d on
now is it is it d oh the d lights up it's not good the d
lights up it lights up it lights up i did it right right i
can't tell then the other thing to hold the wire oh what i
oh i did it yay i did it oh my god i'm so good this all
right now we need food guys we need food now resources okay
food wait i have carrots i can i can give them carrots and
corn oh my god this is it i have okay build guys i'm feeding
my
I knew I could feed them.
Oh my god.
I fucking knew it.
I knew I can feed them.
You guys didn't believe me at first.
It was like, oh, Doki, your people are gonna fucking starve.
I was like, no, no, they're not.
They'll be fine.
There's no way they can starve under my rule.
Okay, and then...
I have grain.
They're gonna be so well fed.
Look!
We did it.
Okay, and then water.
Do we need more water?
Why do you need more water?
Okay, I guess we'll put two pumps.
We'll put another pump here.
Yeah, now you guys are fine.
Yay!
We have to tell people to work the food.
Work on the fucking...
Wait, no, they're already assigned.
already assigned chat they're already automatically assigned
i did good i did good guys my people are happy now see my
people are happy we did it cogsworth we did it all right we
can finally we don't have to care anymore
fucking finally yes I do it's okay we have the the minute
man to defend our place if it gets raided at least the
minute man can defend it right that's the point right my job
here is done oh my god it's the morning I'm gonna sell stuff
though who who is a merchant you've been to good neighbor
yeah i have you sell
yes oh my god he makes ramen oh shit nice all right uh i
don't need any of this okay wait my aid my inventory well i
want to sell other stuff oh he only takes like It only takes
like...
What?
I have a question for you.
Oh, it's you.
What do you want?
You were in the tap house before.
Yeah, that was me.
Uh...
What was that fight about?
You tried to punch out the bartender.
Yeah.
What was that all about?
I thought it was dead obvious.
Okay, to be fair, that was sort of obvious.
Cook decides he's bored with her and she comes crawling back
home to me.
Tough situation.
Everybody has problems.
No, I need your help.
Wait, I can do it.
I've got some money and I'll do it.
I'm going to go back and talk to him and I want you to come
with me.
Of course.
You saw?
You won't take me seriously otherwise.
I don't want to have to really hurt him.
I just want him to leave Darcy alone.
Bro.
Okay, I need money.
You're going to have to make it worth my while.
Yeah.
I can pay you, but I've only got 80 caps.
I hope it's enough.
All right.
I'll help.
Sign me up.
It's okay, Cosworth, if you don't like it.
I have Nick Valentine to replace you.
Wait, why do you need me?
If you were just going to talk to him, why do you need me
along?
I don't want to hurt Cook, but if he doesn't listen to me,
might do you won't dare act so smug when he sees you at my
back and then nobody has to get hurt all right let's do it
are you going can you go there faster
oh i should have went there alone so i can just shoot him
is he gonna go or not will you help me talk to cook get him
to leave my wife alone Yeah, I told you I said I'll- I'll
help.
Okay.
I'll help you.
Good.
I'm sure Cook will back down once he sees you're with me.
Oh, okay.
Let's go.
Okay.
I'll do it alone.
Yeah, I'll do it alone.
This will work better if I talk to Cook by myself.
I don't think so.
Cook might try and talk his way out of it.
And you don't know him.
No!
Now I can't just shoot him!
Oh, nice.
I got $80.
Doesn't matter anyway.
It's alright.
I got $80.
So I'm fine.
It's because he has eyes for his wife only.
That's why my wrist doesn't work, guys.
Guys, he's a lawyer to his cheating wife.
And which I honestly, you deserve better, man.
You deserve better.
How would you even know that son is yours?
That could be the other guys.
Paul, where are you going?
Nowhere you need to worry about.
It's- I don't have zero risk.
He literally has a wife.
I literally- he literally has a wife.
His eyes are only for her.
Can you go faster?
What if I just push him faster?
No, okay, I fucked up.
Pushing him faster makes him go even slower.
Where is it?
Is that the bar?
Okay, that's the bar over there.
It's open.
I want to get this over with it.
I can't get in front of the door.
Oh no, he tricked me into doing a loading screen, guys.
He fucking tricked me.
I literally can't open that...
Okay, there you go.
He tricked me to go to a loading screen.
Oh wait, there's more than one person here.
There's Nelson.
Jesus Paul.
What now?
It's time for you to shut up and listen, Cook.
what the hell is this and what are you doing here i'm here
to watch don't tell me he's hired you to help lean on me
that's right why do you care that's right i should listen to
what paul has to say you're making a mistake getting mixed
up in this yeah we're gonna do listening paul what do you
have to say this time just this oh my god he has this
myself.
Shoot him.
Do it.
It'll be so funny.
Do I just need to kill you?
Is that what you're saying?
Do it.
Give Cook a chance.
Attack Cook.
Calm down.
I just want him to shoot him.
Do I just say attack Cook?
Do it.
I already got my money, though.
You know what?
I already got my money.
Do it.
Better just shoot him, Paul.
Heavens, no.
Mr. Pepper.
What?
What the fuck did I do?
What did I do?
I did it.
Cogsworth, do you still like me?
What's up?
Wow.
Take this.
water thanks cogsworth how do you feel about us yeah how do
you feel about us i wonder the same thing myself things have
certainly changed and not not for the better why not i don't
understand i feel as if we're finally making progress yeah
mr valentine seems to be quite the detective i don't
understand you can head home now right then mom you know
where i'll be oops i I did not mean to dismiss him.
Wait, cancel.
Stay with me.
Wait.
Oh.
Hey.
How are you feeling, Paul?
Hey, Paul.
Hell, I gotta get out of here.
You should, too, before someone walks in here and pins this
on us.
I'm gonna rob him.
Oh.
Cook Residence, shotgun, double shotgun.
Whoa.
I'm gonna take his suit, too.
That's a nice suit.
Wait, if he's dead, I can rob him.
Cogsworth isn't here anymore, right?
Oh my god, wait, he's not here!
Over here!
What?
Wait, he cares?
Don't be late!
What?
Wait, you shot me?
Why did he shot me?
Shut up and listen, Cook.
What the hell is this?
Wait, did Paul shoot me?
Don't tell me he's hired you to help lean on me.
I can't believe it!
He betrayed me!
Stealing is where he draws the line.
I can't believe it.
Just this.
You leave Darcy alone starting now or else.
He draws the line at stealing.
You don't want to pull a gun on me unless you intend to use
it.
You think I won't use it?
Do I just need to kill you?
Is that what you're saying?
okay maybe like wait okay calm down well i mean it's her
white his wife's fault okay well we go why don't you see if
cook is gonna listen i'm sure at this point he's properly
motivated to hear what you have to say oh he never listens
here we go why me it's okay oh my god oh my god now he dies
wait oh my god he does wait no he does don't get me well
hello i don't blame you for anything okay but better than to
fool around with darts paul he used to be one of my best
pals the timeline has changed i've been thinking about
making a break for a while now and well time to action past
time so i have an idea maybe we can help each other put this
all behind us you know what's the idea what's the idea
here's the deal i have some other um businesses on the side
one of them is helping nelson latimer spend his dad's money
to make himself feel like a gangster Who's Nelson?
Yeah, who's Nelson Latimer?
An arrogant little piss ant.
But useful since he has all the money in the world and likes
to think of himself as a budding crime boss.
Me and Nelson are supposed to be meeting some gentleman from
Good Neighbor to exchange Nelson's cash for their chems.
My plan is simple.
We take the money and the chems.
Wait, okay.
Am I just helping them off?
now i have some questions first yeah what is it yeah why now
these guys over all of a sudden oh it isn't all of a sudden
nelson's been complaining about my cut for a while now he
may be thinking about trying to strike out on his own i've
been waiting for the right opportunity to present itself and
here it is anything else i might as well yeah that's it
that's it i think You're in then?
Yeah, I might as well.
Yeah.
I'm in.
You know what?
This is the better timeline.
I get more money.
I promise you won't regret it.
In a few hours, we're both going to be sitting.
Yeah, no, what?
Thank God.
This new timeline is so much better.
I'll get money, too.
This is a better timeline.
I'll get a business offer, guys.
Might as well.
I got 80 bottle caps.
Any business offer?
Yeah, sure, why not?
Yeah, screw Paul in this timeline.
I got free stuff.
Something bad went down in the old museum of witchcraft up
there.
Museum of witchcraft?
Why would anyone even go there?
I've been abandoned forever.
Yeah, Paul already paid me anyway.
Now I get more money.
Exactly.
I did it.
It was a good thing, guys.
sell my stuff I should be able to sell my stuff from
Rodriguez right uh new girl who's new girl kind of travels
fast in Diamond City what can I say names Arturo Rodriguez
if you need protection let's talk protection okay I want to
buy I don't want to sell stuff all right nice okay guys I
don't know what I don't need okay maybe I don't need uh i
don't need road letters i don't need uh oh i have so many
guns i have so many clothes all right we don't need all
these we can sell one of that synthetic truce oh i want to
keep all the voltaic stuff uh i want to sell okay i don't
need another fedora i don't need i don't need all that uh
what else do i not need there's so many things though Oh,
yeah, you guys said the pipe stuff are bad, so I'll sell all
my pipe stuff.
What's the jet?
Oh, it slows time.
I need all of these, though.
I don't need two masks.
Switch categories, please.
What do you mean?
Yeah, you guys all said pipe guns are terrible.
Okay, I can sell that.
I need all these grenades.
Uh, I have like so many good items.
It's so hard to...
Okay, we can...
I think we can sell majority of our clothes.
I...
Um, I admit that we don't need all of these clothes.
Like...
We don't...
We can always grab more suits.
Like, we can always grab more of these.
Alright.
Uh...
Oh, is the letter better than the...
Is the letter better than the raider?
No, it's not.
so I can sell the leather ones.
Uh, but the trip.
Okay, I need all the aid and stuff.
Miscellaneous.
Mons.
Ammo.
Oh my god.
512?
Okay, maybe not 512.
I'd sell like 200 of that.
Right?
Yeah.
And then that should be good.
Confirm trade.
Yay!
So thirsty.
Doctor says I can't drink liquor no more.
Alright.
Well, ammo doesn't weigh anything.
Well, it's okay.
It's fine.
It's fine, guys.
It's okay.
I want money.
Are you here?
Nick?
I did it!
I'm a hero!
Oh god.
It's really me.
I'm a hero!
It's hard to mistake this mug for you.
anyone else you keep laughing at death someday death's gonna
laugh back not as long as i got a few friends back i'm a
friend nick this agency and my job thank you i did it give
me the money pay me about my reward i always gotta ruin the
moment with money talk here every cap we agreed to for
finding him a little extra because she likes me yeah wait
the little extra is a fucking fedora that i'm gonna sell one
case at a time ellie our new friend needs our help first all
right let's get down to business take a seat okay i can
finally sit for real when you're trying to find someone
who's gone missing the devil is in the details tell me
everything you can no matter how uh uh sean looking for my
baby Sean, he's less than a year old.
Why would anyone take him?
Wes, welcome to Jamia Farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Why an infant?
Someone would be taking on all of his care and a baby needs
a lot of it.
What else can you tell me?
Um, he killed my husband's not that important.
You were in a vault when it happened.
Vault 111.
It was some kind of cryo facility.
You were on ice.
more importantly you were underground sealed up it's a lot
of obstacles to get through just to take oh he's dead i
gotta move on my husband's dead my kidnappers there was a
man and a woman they didn't say much but but i remember they
they called me the backup so we're talking a small team
professionals the kind that know to keep their lips tight
when they're on the job I'm not sure what the backup means
though.
Cogsbury, what are you doing?
This isn't a random kidnapping.
Whoever took your kid had an agenda.
There's a lot of groups in the Commonwealth that take
people.
Raiders.
Super mutants.
The gunners.
And of course there's the Institute.
The Institute?
So you think this Institute is responsible?
Well, they're the boogeymen of the Commonwealth.
goes wrong everyone blames them easy to see why those early
models sense of theirs strip whole towns for parts killing
everything in their way wait i want to join the institute
good as human but infiltrate cities and pull strings from
the shadows worst of all no one knows why they do it what
their plan is or where they are not even it sounds strong
i'm a synth myself
of them you're a prototype you're a prototype as far as i
know never seen any other synth like myself there's the
older ones that are dumb as rocks and all metal and there's
the newer ones that are almost human i'm somewhere in
between yeah like you're really you can tell you're really
really old don't lie to me nick you're one of them they made
you yeah i've heard it all before You're a freak.
You've got something to hide.
Yeah, freak.
Wait, aren't you programmed to support the Institute?
People smart enough to build something like me are smart
enough to cover their tracks and arrogant enough to throw
their unwanted trash into the Commonwealth to fend for
itself.
Either way, I need to find Sean.
You're right.
Don't be mean to Nick.
What did these kidnappers look like?
broke his programming they carried a gun that eliminates
like one person I'll never forget that voice low and rough
like that's like everybody in the wasteland cross your face
not much to go on but a tough and commanding voice can get
someone pretty far in the violence business what else um he
was bald one of them came right up to me he had no hair just
like you nick left eye wait you didn't hear the name kellogg
at all did you like the serial who is he do you think he has
sean he named himself after the serial because he saw a
serial box ellie what notes do we have about the kellogg
case the description matches bald head scar reputation for
dangerous employer is and he bought a house here in town
right and he had a kid with him didn't he yeah that's right
the house in the abandoned wet stands the boy with him was
around 10 years old
it's sean it's sean it has to be 10 now somehow don't jump
the gun on me you said you were looking if it's another kid
it has to be sean there's no no other children in this world
look maybe he has kid.
Either way, they both vanished a while back.
Who else could it be?
There's no other children here.
See if we can snoop out where he went.
Security doesn't really go to that part of town, but you two
should still be careful.
How do I make him join my team, guys?
Nick, join my team.
Nick, I don't care about Cox.
Join my team.
Nick.
Come on.
No, join my team, Nick.
No!
I can't open the door, Nick!
Oh, I finished the quest?
Okay, I want Nick to join my team and replace Cogsworth.
You talk to a kid when you're...
She doesn't count.
She's not a kid.
Please...
Why doesn't it take forever to load back?
Oh, there we go.
Okay, I jumped a gun there.
All right, where do we have to go?
Where do we go?
I don't want Ellie to hear this, but I think you should
know.
Everything I dug up about bad news.
What do you mean by that?
More than just a mercenary.
He's a professional.
Quick, clean, thorough.
Has no enemies.
Because they're all dead.
Oh, that's scary.
nine to one odds says he's our man more than just you
identifying his distinguishing features the mo is all him as
well leading a small team to kidnap a baby and leaving one
of the parents alive for later not many mercs in the
commonwealth can pull that off what is it no oh my god this
takes fucking forever can you run can you at least run like
please How far is this place that I have to go?
Okay, where's the objective of this quest?
It doesn't even tell me.
Are you done talking?
Like, can you go a little faster?
Please, why can't you run?
That's all I ask of you.
This is it?
Here we are.
Keep an eye out, will you?
See if I can get this open.
Oh my god, he's perfect.
He can unlock doors.
What can you do?
What can, exactly, walk away.
Wait, you can't unlock this?
Oh my god.
I can't do it.
I'm not smart enough.
We need to find a key.
See that platform in the distance?
Near the city entrance?
Where?
That's the elevator to the mayor's office.
ask around there i'll stay here and see if i can jimmy this
lock can he actually jimmy the lock no okay office is near
the entrance of the city there's a platform that should take
you oh that yellow one oh my god thank god it's in yellow oh
thank god okay all right it's this one right yeah this has
to be it parkour All right, we gotta get a key.
Goodbye, Cosworth.
You're fucking useless.
I can't wait to replace you with a better fucking robot.
You're not even hot.
That used you for eye candy.
Wow, rude.
What?
You think Cosworth's hot?
Huh?
He's afraid of talking to the police.
I bet if I said I was with the Institute, he'd come running.
Do you ever think maybe you could get a man's attention
easier if you use soft.
Whoa.
And shout a little less.
Oh my god, she doesn't need no man.
She needs a woman.
Hey, girl.
You first.
What are you doing here, Piper?
Nah, not until it's in print.
about it in the next issue if you are done crowding the
reception area miss piper the mayor needs to make time for
more responsible citizens i was just leaving anyway the
mayor's receiving visitors as long as they aren't members of
the press did you need help i need to get kellogg's house i
need to talk to someone about kellogg's old house in the
west stands mr kelly i didn't like her anyway guys i like
her she's just not my type if there was something belonging
to the man that you have a claim on it's not that like she
rejected me is that i rejected her before she could reject
me i don't have time i need that key now why is finding this
key so important to you honey do i have money oh i don't
want to give my money away just trust me i'll throw a threat
in you finding my babies all i want to do is find my baby
the man who owned that house kidnapped him i've heard the
sob stories before so say bitch can i threaten her look at
me i should do trust me it's important you have my word you
really thought that would work didn't you i don't think so
maybe we can reach an agreement fine i don't need the bottle
caps for me oh how generous oh there i go again leaving a
key out on my desk and forgetting to put it back i don't
need though it's okay it's all right fine i don't need it i
don't fucking need it
need the money anyway i'll just steal it back i'm gonna
where does she live i'm gonna steal those calves back i'll
show stolen it guys why why did i give her my money
all right let's see we gotta go to kellogg's place wait how
how do i get to kellogg's place was it here wait how do i do
that i forgot how to get there naturally like oh it's like
here oh it's over here i see the stairs all right i'm smart
i have two intelligence that's smart enough that's enough to
pass like first grade it's the wasteland so you don't need
to be smart you just gotta have the fucking guns i do i got
the keys and even for my baby boy let's take a look around
Kellogg must have left something behind oh I can steal now I
can sell it up I can make back the money I lost I can make
back all the money I lost guys this is it
Is there something on the desk?
You don't understand Cogsworth.
You don't fucking care.
Where is it?
I'm telling you, something's not right.
The broom?
Look for anything out of sorts.
Switch.
A button.
Hey, Valentine.
Keep looking.
There'll be something here.
What is it?
It's so small.
It has to be...
No, that's not it.
just a bed.
There's another sleeping bag.
There's two sleeping bags here.
Did you see it?
Where is it?
Hidden.
Oh, I'm hidden.
Huh?
Oh my god, I got picked up.
Found
it!
I'm so smart!
That's one way to hide a room.
Nuka cola.
look at this hey valentine look at that all of kelog's
favorite things
oh my god look at all these free stuff oh my god used oil
when it's stout beer 44 caliber bullets cigars oh my god
stimpax i need those interesting brand won't lead us
anywhere on its own now
How do you know about dog meat?
Drag a man sent for miles.
Why don't you go fetch him and let him have a whiff?
See if he picks up the trail.
Before you head out, I know this is personal business.
If you have to face Kellogg on your own, just say so.
Besides, you already have plenty of company.
sniffing through the commonwealth after one man.
Wait, come with me.
I want you with me.
Is he my companion now?
Oh my god, yes, leave.
Leave.
I'm my new best friend.
You say jump.
I'll say how high.
Yay!
Time!
He's my new companion now.
Let's go!
out i found a hotter robot for my eye candy leave me alone
coxworth grosses thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you king shaming for robot appearances now turkey
shake my head look if i'm gonna have a robot that's gonna
follow me around he better be good eye candy for me
This one's hotter.
He has legs.
Where are your legs, Cogsworth?
Oh, hey, dog meat.
You're here.
Dog meat.
Get the scent, boy.
Yeah, get the scent.
Got the scent?
Got something, boy.
Let's go!
Is that Cogsworth just slowly walking back?
That's right.
Slowly do the walk of shame, Cogsworth.
That's fucking right!
Look at the person I replaced you with!
Hanging out with Valentine, huh?
Good for you.
Yeah.
Head over there.
Links are DLC.
When Cogsworth gets those legs, then we'll talk.
The walk of shame.
He has to know his place.
guys oh no oh no back to loading screen I am back to the
loading screen all right here we go where is it dog meat
where is he where's my son how far is it come on boy where
the fuck is my son my ap oh my god i forgot to get back all
my no congressman's holding so much of my items
oh no i knew i forgot to do something i forgot i forgot to
take back my items wait you're somewhere san francisco
sunlight's preferred brand all right yeah search for these
track him he took everything into the voice i can't believe
it now and i said i forgot to take the stuff back before i
before i should talk to him now he's gonna throw them all
away he's gonna throw them to the curb he's gonna throw it
from a balcony
oh shit oh my god guys guys Guys, why did you not tell me to
heal?
Guys!
Why did you not tell me to heal, guys?
Nuka Cola.
Yeah.
Fucking fuck off.
Fuck off.
Yeah, what is Nick?
Nick?
Oh my god.
I need to eat these guys.
Oh shit, he's extra radiated!
I'm crippled!
Bro!
Oh, that's a dog!
Oh my god, I'm limping.
I'm limping.
Somebody help.
There's a stim pack.
Didn't I not loot stim packs?
oh i did okay i'm okay now it was just i'm okay now i'm not
i can walk again i can walk again guys
go to the stat screen why that can i upgrade oh i can i need
what no i can you guys lied
yes use vats i don't need vats i have pure skill Super chat!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Alright.
Can't believe it.
Those fucking moles.
Oh, I can use stim packs from this.
Oh, I can use stim packs from a stat screen.
Vats?
Vats are for pussies.
I don't need vats when I can smash.
Come on.
Go dock me.
Go.
Where is he?
Search clues for Kellogg?
Is it in here?
Blood splatters?
Look at the blood splatters.
Whoa!
What the f- Oh, that's what I looted from.
Oh hey, look at all these free stuff.
What did you see, boy?
What is it, boy?
Bloody bandages.
Dog meat can track this.
Okay, boy.
Let's track him.
Yeah, no need for a vass when she got the vass.
Exactly, Zane.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
Where are they?
Oh, shit.
The evo's fine.
There you go.
Oh!
Bad boy!
Holy shit.
Oh, my God.
This is why I got you, Nick.
Bam!
Oh!
Did you see that dog fight?
Bro, my dog, this is the legal type of dog fighting.
Because those are evil dogs.
Wait, we did it at dog meat.
Wait, where's dog meat?
Where did he go?
Where did dog meat go?
Wait, actually, where the fuck did my dog go?
Guys, I lost my dog.
Guys.
I lost him.
My dog's gone.
Their evil dies.
We just literally saw two dogs fighting.
Wait, where's dog meat?
Dog meat?
Where did dog meat go?
I need to turn on the quest.
I might as well.
Reunions.
Follow dog meat.
Where did he go?
Oh, he went this way.
Is that it?
Is that the real quest?
No.
This is a quest.
He's over here.
Oh, he's barking at me.
He's calling me stupid.
Bro, dog meat.
Wear a vest.
We need to wear a reflected vest, dog meat.
I can barely see where you are.
I'm gonna loot that.
I'm not dog meat.
Where are they?
Where's Kellogg?
The cereal.
Oh, my God.
That's a bear.
That's a fucking bear.
Why?
I can't fucking fight a bear.
I'm gonna fight a bear.
Oh, that is not the Oh, okay, but what?
Oh, how much damage do I do?
I do.
Oh, that was a mistake.
That was a mistake.
Guys, guys, guys, I don't
It's not just a bear.
Guys, it was not just a bear.
Guys, guys, it was...
Oh my god.
I had to fight the dogs again?
Alright, guys.
It was not just a bear.
I've learned...
I've learned that it was absolutely much worse than just a
bear.
Alright.
it was it was a radioactive bear i can't believe i didn't
save i can't believe we're gonna kill a bear today it's okay
low 7 the low 15 zone what like it's hard
we can do this i believe in us can't be that difficult
Bloody bandages.
Find him.
Dog meat can track this.
That nose is second to none.
What do you think, boy?
Enough to go on?
We'll be fine, right?
We'll be fine.
We'll be so fine.
We're going to be so healthy.
All right, we're going to grab...
Let's see.
A comfort grip.
Ooh, this is a better pistol, actually.
And then...
Oh, I should grab a shotgun.
Never mind.
I'm grabbing a shotgun.
We're going to be fucking shooting bears.
We're going to grab...
What the...
What the fuck?
Alright, just fucking grab a pistol.
These guys take so long.
Bro, what the fuck?
It was easier to just...
Whoa!
Okay, I'm fucking grabbing a...
The shotgun sucks!
The shotgun fucking sucks!
What the hell?
Look at this pistol.
Watch this pistol.
Oh my god, the pistol is faster.
Look, see?
Wait, no.
Yeah, the pistol is so much faster.
Get you some dog meat.
Alright, guys.
I gotta figure this out.
I gotta figure this out what gun to use.
Because all these guns fucking suck.
The auto pistol.
Let's see.
I don't know.
What's the best gun to fight the...
The mini gun?
To fight the bear?
Okay, maybe...
This gun.
This gun would be okay.
Alright, we're gonna save.
We're gonna save.
Alright.
We're gonna see a bear soon.
Alright, it's bear time.
Oh, that's the worst gun I could use?
Okay.
Okay, all right.
Okay, maybe we can do something with this gun, right?
Where's the bear?
Is he here?
Is he here again?
Is the bear back?
Wait, was that just...
Oh, wait, there he is.
Oh, God.
Hit it.
No.
Give me the crit.
Is
that...
Oh god, Nick, shoot him!
Nick, shoot him for the love of God!
Shoot the bear!
Oh god.
Sacrifice yourself!
Nick, sacrifice yourself for me!
Oh!
Sacrifice yourself!
Don't be regen HP right now!
Oh, I ran out of ammo.
I ran out of ammo.
Oh, what gun has ammo right now?
Oh my god, I fucking knew you would be killed!
No!
Holy shit.
Please, please, please, please, please, please, please.
Oh my god, please, God, please, God, please.
regen.
Wait, wait, wait.
I'm trying.
Oh, the Dragon Buster.
The Dragon Buster.
Oh, God.
Reload.
Nick.
Take this.
Good job, Nick.
Oh, my God.
Where is he?
I can't even see him.
3% I'll take my odds
Did I hit him?
Guys, I don't think I'll hit him It's okay You got this,
Nick We did it It was that easy Oh my god
Holy shit, we fucking did it Oh my god, let me fucking save
Holy fuck We did it.
Use your companions as bait so you can live.
The dokeybird strat.
Guys, who wants to be my companion, guys?
Not even close.
We did it.
You're right.
It's not we.
I did it.
You're right, guys.
You're right.
I did it.
What's this?
Are you fucking kidding me?
A decoy, huh?
Clever.
Is that search enough?
Is that it?
Wait, where did- where dog meat is?
There he is, so.
Oh, hey, more clues.
Oh, more sitting down.
all right where you want to go dog meat where are you going
where are we going dog meat
whoa whoa whoa whoa
oh my god there's more how much more vicious snar don't
worry dog me i'll come over
I got the games.
See, it's that easy.
Oh, shit.
Easy.
Legendary!
Okay.
Did I miss?
How did I miss?
Oh, God.
Don't let him hit me.
No!
Oh, my God.
You fucking kidding me.
You brought it to...
Okay.
guys
how is I supposed to know he one shots oh thank god at least
I saved after the bear oh thank god I saved after the bear
oh thank fucking god I would have been so sad if I had to do
the bear again oh my god it was planned chat it was planned
so I can disarm this a decoy huh clever guys it was planned
do i hit it guys don't hit it guys
okay i'm gonna call it here i think
all right i'm gonna call you i think that's a good
This is where we're calling today.
This is where we're calling it today.
I think that was the point where I was like, my mind's not
working anymore.
You guys were like, oh, you can disarm it.
Use your vets and you can disarm it.
But I think somebody meant like, use your vets to find like
mines.
But then I thought like, oh, use my vets to disarm it.
but then I realized, oh, they meant, like, if you can't,
don't know where the mines are, you can use your vats.
But I didn't read the last part.
I read the beginning where someone said, use vats.
And then I didn't read the end of the sentence.
All right, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You know, Piper is a good companion to you.
She has a face and legs.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
But she's not a hot robot.
That's the only thing, guys.
That's the only thing that, like, is the deal-breaker.
Oh, my God.
Today was a very long, long day today.
I'm sorry I didn't stream more fun.
I sorry I didn't do a longer follow-up stream.
But we did a really long Monopoly stream.
So I'm going to add that in together.
So it was a double stream today.
But I did have a lot of fun today, guys.
I hope you guys had a lot of fun as well chat.
It was a very very long day But hope you guys enjoy today.
I actually didn't even eat dinner yet.
I didn't eat dinner yet So I'm gonna go and order some food
for dinner But I really was a great time just spending my
day with you get dragons and as always everybody Say
hydrated posture check get up and move around to get that
blood flowing And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.
Sorry, it was like a really quick ending, everyone.
Sorry, sorry.
I just really want to get food.
So I can't chat for too long.
Because I won't order food before places close down.
So I'll see you guys next.
I'll see you guys the day after tomorrow.
Bye-bye.